i'm very pleased to say and as you can
see the shadow climate change secretary
ed miliband joins us once again good to
see you this morning mr mullivant um i
wonder if we just might start with that
breaking news that we've been hearing on
which i'm sure you'll have a view i mean
clearly not a huge surprise the chance
they're perhaps talking a good game
pointing out the numbers on payroll that
have increased but when you're talking
about you know workers pay lagging
behind because of inflation like it's
only going to exacerbate a pretty grim
situation well this is a very grim
sort of moment you know the the biggest
real terms fall in pay that we've seen
on record it shows the scale of the cost
of living crisis that people are facing
and it shows why labor was right why kia
starman was right yesterday to take the
decisive action he did on energy bills
and you know that is the thing that is
driving the cost of living crisis the
most and and we face a choice neil in
this country we can say four thousand
pound energy bills which is what the
forecasts are for for january three and
a half thousand pounds in october that
that can go ahead that that can happen
all we can act and labor has chosen to
act with a fully funded plan and i've
got to say the tory candidates will be
out tonight in their debate
they must now answer you know families
watching this program will be asking you
want to be the prime minister of this
country tell us where you stand on the
biggest issue and i i've looked at this
in a lot of detail over the last few
weeks there is only one viable solution
in my view to really protect people to
stop 50 of people falling to fuel
poverty and that is what labor set out
yesterday and we'll dig into the detail
of it in just a second but but in terms
of the popularity of the policy i mean
you must be pretty pleased with the fact
that what 75 of conservative voters
support extending the price cap for for
the energy price cap for another six
months yeah but and you know why this is
it's because people recognize this that
of course the poorest in our society are
going to be very badly affected the
worst affected by this but the scale of
this meal is so great that in a country
where 40 percent of people have less
than 1500 pounds worth of savings
where you know we're talking about
bills that we've never ever seen before
we can't just say this is about the
poorest and this is the point this is
this is the big choice that we face in
the country are we going to act with
with decisiveness and we can pay for
this because you know we know those oil
and gas giants are making billions now
the conservative party chooses not to
tax those oil and gas chance at the
level they should be we're choosing a
different choice we're talking about a
plan that will be in effect for what six
months you're not telling me that you
expect energy prices to come down in the
next year and a half
we're gonna look we looked at the
situation we face for the coming months
for this winter and we've acted
decisively and we've shown you all that
you keep saying that yeah and we've
short-term plans so what happens after
the six months when the energy prices
continue to rise or remain at
historically high level i look forward
to coming back and talking to you about
that then but but let me people i'm
asking about it well no and i'm going to
tell you people should be in no doubt
about at the fact that we will act look
we have shown
we're a responsible opposition we want
to be as well so we've shown that we've
got a fully funded plan
and when we come up when we come forward
uh in the months running up to april we
will also come forward with a fully
funded plan but people should be in no
doubt we will act at the scale of the
emergency that we face and i think
people you can say fairer than that you
know people are asking what's going to
happen about this winter we've shown
what we'll do you're talking about the
best part of 30 billion pounds for the
first six months another six months
lightly off the back of it another 30
billion pounds and this is a huge amount
of the money right okay well let's play
this unless and unless you continue it
in perpetuity you know
well
you're not perpetrating unless you
continue doing it until energy prices
come down you know the idea that you're
gonna be able to save any money because
inflation will come down to nonsense
well let's talk about
whether there is a money available to
act
because it's not like this money that
we're all paying in our bills
disappearing to thin air it's going to
energy companies to oil and gas
as well doesn't it
well hang on a minute we're talking
about different parts of the energy
sector but what i'm saying to you is
that these oil and gas companies rishi
sudan was saying he was going to take 5
billion pounds from them after we urged
you month on upon month to do it we've
shown how we can get an extra eight
billion pounds uh in yesterday's
announcement it's not like there isn't
money available some people will say
it's not sustainable we can't act we
can't act to protect people i disagree
we can act to protect people that's what
we've done that's what we'll continue to
do when you're talking about expenditure
of now on 60 billion over you know the
course of 12 months if this plan remains
in place for that why don't you simply
nationalize
well because that wouldn't be a solution
to the problem we face that would prove
cheaper over the long run well let me
just explain what what i mean by that we
have an energy set company in the public
sector that's bulb energy that went bust
as a result of terrible government
regulation
balboa will demand this subsidy as well
so there are longer term issues we've
got to look at in relation to ownership
we've said that many times but as a in
terms of this crisis in terms of this
crisis we face we want every penny
to go to help cut people's bills and
that is what yesterday's announcement
delivers and i just come back to this
point neil because it is important
august 26 we all know the cap goes up
september the 5th the new prime minister
gets elected i'm saying the conservative
party candidates rishi sunak and liz
trust have got to come forward and tell
us what are they going to do not to wait
until the the bills of the the cap's
gone up direct debits start rising but
to tell us now i mean it's not it's not
as if secure starters stood in 2019 on a
platform of perhaps nationalized oh you
know he did in fact stand on that
particular platform i'm just wondering
what the difference is between the
situation in 2019 at where he made you
know the 10 pledges in the manifesto and
he said this public services and public
hands not making profits for
shareholders supporting common ownership
of rail mail energy and water ending
outsourcing on nhs local government
injustice but there energy sure what's
changed well we're continuing to look at
what the right long-term solution is for
our energy system
and that's the job that i'm doing i tell
you what the difference is between now
and 2019 we face an absolutely massive
bills crisis and the question that
people are asking is what are you going
to do now not what's your long-term plan
in relation to the energy sector what
are you going to do now now we do also
have a long-term plan and i'll tell you
what's the most important thing is
what's what's really going to deal with
this bill's crisis in the long term it's
getting off fossil fuels it's driving
forward on solar on wind on off shore
which is what we're doing why then are
you subsidizing the energy bills of the
richest in society why not take this 29
billion pounds pump it through the
benefit system so it gets to people who
are most in need and at the same time
encourage those who can afford to pay
their bills to perhaps reduce their
energy consumption i'll tell you exactly
the climate change i'll tell you exactly
why it's about people like the midwife
in my constituency who's not on benefits
who wrote to me saying i don't i i work
my husband works i don't know how i'm
going to be able to describe a midwife
is rich i'm not talking about this well
hang on you just said neil that we
should just do it through the benefits
system what i'm saying to you is there's
a choice here okay you could say you're
just gonna do it for people on benefits
and i'm saying to you that what that
would mean is that there are people in
the middle people who so often miss out
who will not get help and who will say
we literally can't afford to pay our
energy bills we are going to face
exactly the same problems that some of
the poorest in our society face and you
know just let me give you this one
figure which which people have
the experts have told us which is that
if the four thousand pound bill happens
four thousand pound cap we'll have more
than fifty percent of people in our
country more than fifty percent of
people
in fuel poverty that has never happened
before in this country and we're not
willing to tolerate it so why is there
no labour assistance for business
contained in this energy strategy what
about those small sizes well there is
good there's a billion pounds of help
for business for targeting the most
energy-intensive industries because they
face the biggest problem steel ceramics
and others you're completely right
business is facing real real problems in
relation to this and we said we will we
have put money inside we did it in the
package that we set out in january and
we've done it again in what we unveiled
yesterday i do want to talk obviously on
your briefing we're talking about
record-breaking heat waves at the moment
now we're expecting severe flooding um
across the united kingdom to what extent
do we really need to get our to put our
house in order i mean what would the
labour party do that is markedly
different from the commitments that the
government have made to sort out our
our kind of contribution to climate
change well there's two things that we
need to do the first is we need to drive
much further and much faster let me give
you some examples onshore wind we
continue to have a moratorium on in
england on onshore wind that is
completely wrong it goes against all
logic and evidence
we we have some of the worst insulated
homes in europe we have a plan to
insulate the 19 million cold drafty
homes in our country to cut our gas used
to cut climate uh emissions uh as well
solar energy offshore wind nuclear what
we need is a what i call a clean energy
sprint and the government has dithered
and delayed and has not acted and we
would just briefly because i know you
have to go and the bosses at the water
companies i mean you unders you read the
same reports getting those million
pounds millions and pounds in bonuses
whilst you know people are struggling
because of water shortages around the
country water is being wasted in an
industrial scale
what would you do to solve well it's
scandalous it shouldn't be happening and
the regulators should have powers to act
on this and frankly there are real
questions to be asked about the
regulation of the water companies in
terms of what we're seeing and those
bonuses and what is happening and and it
is a scandal and i think people are
rightly outraged about it ed milan
always good to have you in the studio
thank you very much